welcome to this video playing PT crew
pre come here and dress ki liras let's
play from Cyprus as I recently learned
let's see we get probably Queens gambit
here or Bishop before yep that's the
alternative in numazu star move which
however is not quite the new so as I
don't have not played d4 yet knight c6
hmm that's an interesting way to play it
after d4 we transpose to we transpose to
the enemies of Zurich but I have a queen
not see 3 mm I don't really want that
but I can't start with before here maybe
I don't have to play interesting yeah I
don't have to play the movie for here
which is a big difference in some cases
I can occupy the long diagonal and it's
an open diagonal with Bishop b2 coming
this sum is interesting yeah that that
is that is making lots of sense he wants
to prepare a five I wonder if this is a
situation where i should actually switch
plans go back to deform we should be to
e5 let's switch back to this idea I'm
controlling a five and if he can play 94
maybe no 94 and then if I was thinking
yeah someone pointed out to me that
while PT is french for for dual the
second part of this this name is
actually something Greek and it's
supposed to be not very friendly however
I don't I didn't look it up don't know
what it means so if someone is
knowledgeable in the Greek language
please some well if it's if it's very
naughty you shouldn't post it but will
be interesting to learn what this
actually means okay yeah 94 I can take
f7 here even for quincy for check then
getting the night back hmm Bishop f7 if
the King moves Queen to be three I don't
know that it really has any compensation
for that I don't believe it to be honest
Jim King takes Quincy for check and I'm
getting the night back would already be
two pawns up all right maybe maybe you
can get one of those points back with
this activity but there should be six
and so on but two points I cannot
believe it maybe he moves the king and
I'm going to play queen bee three
having the rook still under attack check
I'm also threatening age seven so it's
it's not it's it's not yeah it's not so
am so easy to find find something good
here for for him okay so I thought we
should be too we're just keeping keeping
this protected preparing um rookie one
yeah that was was the obvious choice hmm
ok I can play Queen g-form simply
keeping an eye on the long diagonal and
okay he can get a pawn back now but I
doubt that it's really going to be
sufficient Bishop f3 yeah that's an
interesting question actually I can take
with the jeep on okay I he wants to play
his Bishop to c4 I think or the Queen
would be three I oh ok that that's a
point that's that's a really valid point
Queen d3 ism is a nuisance really so
maybe I should play it a bit differently
let's let's put it back and then
reconsider after Bishop g5 I can also go
to see to allowing this this trade trade
here or 2d three actually so Bishop f3
Queen d8 GF 95 kingi to yeah that that's
that's quite ok
hmm that's quite ok returning one porn
but keeping keeping one and still
relying on the fact that I have the
bishop against the night you know in a
very open position the bishop is very
good on the long diagonal I came so
taking here 95 kingi to should be should
be really good and don't want to take
the the night it's really quite clear
that i have them the better minor PCM
unfortunately i cannot go to deform but
not a big deal we should before i can
take or you could have taken in that
case ok so just just lucrative one takes
takes Knight a 3 root g 7 ok yeah that's
that should be good ok so i can trade
that one now just keep the pawn
ok man I don't mind to have be five
plate here
fixing those pawns on dark squares k
some skin gain some more space no bishop
is nicely taking lots of squares maybe
rook f7 as I move that I should have
looked at he wants to play c6 maybe c5
time morning ok yeah I have four against
two there on them on the King side
that's why I should try to decide the
game getting pawns rolling it's still a
couple of moves away from threatening
anything on the on the queenside
check check h6 is hanging so I'm going
to get this pawn and then while those
two points should be pretty pretty good
all rights only hope is something with
the sea para check that doesn't really
look very likely to a sham ok going to
g5 check where it should be ok check
check check
yeah two points a bit much black resins
jam that wasn't horrible opening opening
disaster here with this this some 5 and
94 um yeah this looks also quite um yeah
I don't know it looks a bit illogical
taking and giving me this in one move
it's very likely that if he just stays
up late we should be too at some point
and then you can still take if you want
but this is really not working at all
opening up the position for my bishop
pair and this is simply simply not
working that so this is plus 2 we r plus
1.6 mm okay yeah I mean we're ways he's
supposed to go with an idea that that's
really am an issue going here that's
it's really a disaster i'm a pawn up the
bishops thats too much and here are
classes this just coming here but should
be too looks okay here yeah maybe if
maybe i have something better this is
okay until i reconsidered yeah what I
wasn't so sure about here is if we think
of this originally I wanted to do here
but well this is hmm yeah this is kind
of fishing and the other okay the engine
is going down 2-0 already actually I
feel very uncomfortable here it those
ideas so I prevented that and repeated
once the comp wants to play Queen f4
yeah I didn't consider that very much a
thought giving him the tempo isn't
making much sense but ok this is um
still a good position but Queen d3 i
think is okay I'm returning this pawn
here but it's just a in just a very good
position where really he has no
compensation for being a pawn down
it's it's it's rather white who has the
better pure position let's say because
of the bishop here I'm taking with the
rook that's important not with the King
because this is just just a bit too much
he cannot cannot defend here the
seventh-ranked so you went here here
yeah and here we can you can you can
debate but I think I think what I did
was was okay I made one mistake I think
here here probably you can play rook f7
now which is I mean and say okay even
that is not a big problem i have i have
this reverse reverse reply hmm yeah okay
was I was briefly worried that rook f7
is a bit of a problem but ok well yeah I
think what I would have played is ok
it's mostly mostly the engine moves
actually check check check yeah I know
you can really test to just move the
pawns up this chat chat simply too much
with the active King and it's two
against one basically yeah the opening
here was the the reason for blacks
defeat ok well thanks for watching